[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as John likes to call it Dear John
and Hank it's Katherine I'm Katherine
green we're here debut on door Hank
we're here to give you some dubious
advice answer your questions and bring
you all the week's news from both Mars
and AFC Wimbledon it's gonna be so good
how are you doing Katherine I'm all
right
it's turning starting to be spring here
in Montana mm-hmm so had any recent
visits from Taylor Swift no no um I
don't think I don't think she knows that
Montana exists sure she does
yeah sure she does I bet she needs to go
to mountains she's like over there in
the Swiss Alps or something
I bet I bet she's here right now and you
just don't know what she's living a hot
lifestyle you know who is here right now
actually Ingrid Nilsen really yes she is
in she's down near postman what that's
what I said I was like I see how it is
oh my goodness
I mean Bozeman's pretty far it's not
close it's really you know it's like one
of those things where you're like you're
in Ohio and you didn't tell me that is a
completely different thing yeah then
being in Montana aliens a lot of Montana
but what's she doing in Bozeman I don't
know some thing yeah it's important yeah
cool thing I'm sure I'm sure
yeah well well I think we'll see here
when we're in LA soon so that'll be good
well fingers crossed uh Wow but I bet I
bet Taylor's here too
I feel like I think she is I don't know
where she's at you have a feeling I do
I'm just feeling Taylor Swift is in the
areas nearby no don't think I don't
think you're right cosmically she's
nearby
closer than she could be yeah if she
works if she was in space yeah she's not
in space she's here on her yeah just
like all the other earthlings right for
the most part yes she's a very very tiny
tiny percentage of human Earthlings who
are not here on earth and they're still
very close yeah real close oh yeah I
recently I found out that oftentimes the
space station is closer than lots of
places on earth so I got this you could
see the space station
and it's much closer to you than like
Florida sure yeah or anywhere on the
other side of the globe yeah definitely
definitely yeah
even if you could go straight through
yeah still closer like like the people
on on the space station are closer to
people most of the time than people in
like New Zealand it's a really big
planet you could be yeah it's a it's a
big planet big planet is round and the
atmosphere is very thin
it's very precariously thin hair of
fiying Li thing yes yes I'm getting
anxiety let's stop talking about all
right
how am i doing is the question oh how
and how are you also doing Hank I'm good
I have a little bit of gas hmm that's
pretty much constant sit here on the
floor and even talk about it you know I
think I might unbutton my pants yeah you
should be comfy yeah
got a makeup like myself comfy what's
that face that was me
suppressing a burp oh of course
[Laughter]
this is already better this is already
more comedy than any dear Hank and John
nobody wants to hear that
I don't know Katherine maybe gonna let
one or two ago people would really enjoy
it we'll see and I also I on my tumblr I
made a critical statement about the song
Cecilia and the satellite it wasn't
really a critical statement deep in it I
guess traditionally critical in that
joke well it was a bit of a joke and
also I like I actually feel like if I
was a songwriter I would have played it
different but of course that's fine and
like different creative people make
different creative choices there but yes
I was just talking about how I feel that
the metaphor would have been more
powerful without the addition of and you
or the sky because a satellite implies a
two-body system in which one thing
revolves around another that's what a
satellite is it's anything that revolves
around the moon is a satellite yes and
and I was like what a beautiful thought
and then he says and you're the sky and
that's just like messes the whole
metaphor I might even does the sky meet
you dad this guy is like the thing that
we see from the earth so like who is the
third impartial observer
that is observing both he the satellite
and she the sky is it just like dude to
some listener dude dude dude did you and
Hanks like wait a minute what do you
mean when you say sky
we were watching agent Carter last night
and there was a periodic table in the
background and it didn't have any of the
atomic weights on it and I was like what
is even the point of that periodic table
yeah beautiful drawing it's just for art
you can look up nothing of interest on
this I don't know not useful yeah I'm a
whole point I had to point out to Hank
that uh the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
is not based on science yeah I did it I
did I did what did I say oh they were
talking about this photon beam
oh god no and that and yeah and so
they're shooting a bunch of photons
they're using words that science has
made yeah but they don't mean what
science right doesn't mean but then
they're talking about how it's going to
travel in a parabolic arc oh yeah and
I'm like why would photon their their
photon slits there they have no mass I
mean they're very slightly parabolic arc
due to the distortion of space-time by
the gravity of Earth sure that is the
only but like that's not gonna matter
not on the scale you're aiming in no no
yeah anyway so I sometimes I am
sometimes that guy yeah and I don't want
to be that guy and several people on
tumblr criticized me of being that guy
oh well yeah I mean you kind of are that
guy but you know it's you're not doing
it maliciously no no it's just no it was
like when Neil deGrasse Tyson is that
guy I'm cut sometimes I'm like oh come
on just have a good time but then I'm
like why are there no atomic weights on
my periodic table you destroyed a good
time Hank yeah it's his way of having a
good time yes all right
which yeah you know that's fine that's
fine everybody has their own laying out
with him every day find your bliss Neil
deGrasse Tyson whatever it is
I was popular media for pirates
depictions of things yeah Wow do you
have a short poem for us Catherine I do
have one prepared it is the shortest one
I could find good for you thank you for
doing that I appreciate that very much
and we don't have to talk about it
afterwards it's by D H Lawrence who was
a writer is he no longer and apparently
a poet oh he is no longer okay yes he is
a former it's called tourists okay there
is nothing to look at anymore everything
has been seen to death
great great dear Hank and John poem
Catherine I you look really proud of
yourself right now as a person who knows
nothing about poetry and has minimal
interest in it not sure you like poetry
more than I do I suppose I mean I I can
appreciate it but I I don't seek it out
that's for sure yeah I mostly have a
bike I just feel like I my brain has has
very structured ways of understanding
the world and challenging to absorb
taking a long time for me to develop
these structures and they work and they
function well and then when like poetry
is sort of designed to disrupt those
those structures yes and then I'm just
like I can't work everything breaks I
don't have I don't have those I don't
have those other ways of understanding
the world they're just not there it is
very challenging for you all right I
understand Catherine we've got a
question oh let's do it we're gonna do
questions this one this one is from
Michaela who asks dear Hank and
Katherine dogs and cats have a higher
average body temperature than humans
which causes them to always feel warm
and soft and cuddly when we touch them
does this mean that when they touch us
they feel a cold sack of human flesh
since our body temperature is lower than
theirs oh I mean have you ever touched
another human that's yeah they feel warm
yeah ish they feel on touching yeah and
generally the apartment
touching isn't colder than apart you're
touching I have always been impressed by
my pets abilities for it for like me to
come in from the outside wintertime and
go to them and be like give me a cuddle
and they don't like if I do that to you
oh yeah yeah yeah scratching and biting
yeah but if but like pets are just like
mom just lying here I don't know like
how are you not totally uncomfortable
when I put my frigid hands on your lemon
didn't even have hair on her stomach
and I just be like yeah since she never
cared yeah I don't know she didn't have
fat either so I don't I don't know how
she managed no but oh yes I think they
do but I think that it says a lot about
them that they don't seem to mind yeah I
I think that's yeah that's the thing
it's like what is it unpleasant
therefore right not necessarily mm-hmm
yeah yeah maybe they're hot yeah they
always rub up against people and they're
like oh you're so cool that does not
does not seem to be our pets though
because when the fireplace worked which
it no longer does they would just lay
there oh yeah until oh yeah until until
like until Siri yeah until like
dangerously hot so I don't know I think
that they yeah yes I think the answer
question is yes I think yes I think it's
yes but also it's not as impactful to
them because they yeah can manage their
temperature better maybe maybe yeah I
mean I think humans are just wusses yeah
we're just not good at it like I'm cold
right now yeah I wearing a hat and a
hoodie Oh God
inside yeah yeah so yeah we're just bad
at being people yeah just all animals
better be an animal yes because I have
other skills yeah we have yeah cuz we've
gotten so good at being like oh and this
is bothering me I'll fix the problem
like oh this is bothering me so yep yeah
what am I gonna do I got I got two
choices die or live with it sucking it
up sucking it up good animals are good
at that
thank you animals for being so good at
that yep well thanks for your question
Makayla no weird thought to have had but
I have another question Hank okay it's
from Natalie and she says dear Hank and
John or Catherine my brother and I are
currently fighting over a ball which I
took from him because I wanted it you
have a very good grammar now I know
you're wondering how could a
two-year-old send emails that is what I
was wondering yes well I am in fact 16
and my brother is 14 because I took the
ball my brother's now taking my things
he has my textbook this will most likely
continue until one of us gives in I will
not be the one anyway I was wondering
what's the most petty thing you guys
have fought over any interesting insults
get thrown around now I'm assuming he
was hoping to get this question answered
by you and John right yes that's not
what's gonna happen John's not here so
and as she I believe oh sorry yes
Natalie I don't know that's weird you
just assumed that it was two brothers
because because that was more the more
likely situation for the bickering yeah
it does yeah well anyway even though I
read Natalie at the beginning you did
sorry Natalie
um well first let me say you can talk
about petty arguments you've had with
John that way even with even though he's
not here to defend himself
no I want to know but I want to first
give Natalie some advice oh sure yeah
give that ball by act seriously come on
I mean you're gonna be the one just you
know you are I know that you're the
older sibling here and and there's a
power dynamic and that power dynamic is
I'm sure has a lot of different stuff
tied up in it in your sibling
relationship but remember that you as
the older see I'm coming this we're both
coming at this Catherine and I as the
younger sibling and we're like come on
you'd be the bigger person either
because your brother a 14 year old is
doing his best to keep up to appearances
and be like hi I am I am equal on equal
footing with you but he's not yeah
he's the younger sibling and he's always
going to feel that were slighted yes the
thing you'll have to learn is you know
when you have power when you're in a
position of power yeah
you should not abuse it and also
understanding when you are in a position
of power which can be very difficult and
is the source of the majority of
conflicts in the world
hmm when like misunderstanding how
powerful you are I'm staying yes yes
that's that is how that is how I feel
that is a feeling that I have I have not
done any psychological or sociological
research on this but do we have any
arguments any useless petty Fannie's
argument yeah silence uh uh we never
fight you you do not like it when I
leave the lights on oh you're always
like hey are you what yeah I guess
that's a thing yeah cups oh yeah what
the cups is a definite thing I'm like
why what is this your cup is this also
your cup how about that one over there
is that your cup I can see three of your
cups from where I'm sitting Hank why do
you have so many cups why did you just
get a new cup yeah I mean some yeah
that's fine though you know I mean on
the lit on the level of yeah so that is
a been fighting argument that is yes and
I and I am like it's not even really an
argument I'm just kind of like you did
it again
you know cuz you know you know it's your
wrong I do I'm like arguing about it
what happened was I forgot about
everything in the world but I forgot
that the rest of the world existed and I
was thirsty yep thing what I do when I'm
thirsty as I go to the cupboard and get
a cup and put liquid in it yes I don't
think about whether I have a cup this is
important
husband-wife communication like you have
to know these things about each other
they're like
Catharine these conceives of the world
differently than i do you see a bunch of
objects yes around
I do not know I'd never live eeeh Stu
the object I never I have no idea
objects are around oh yeah man
everything I have like I can tell it
like objects that I'm focused on yeah
like the microphone I'm very aware of
the microphone right now I'm very aware
of where it is and and I feel and when
we're recording games with Hank stuff
I'm always like hath and be more aware
of the microphone you have no idea where
it is and I'm constantly laser focused
on where that thing is so that people
can hear me and you're like aw for here
there's having fun like slip back on the
couch I'm like come on we're making good
in here yes whereas the world is just
full of objects for me no yeah it is
literally just cluttered with objects so
many they're all and they're all looking
at me and they want me to do something
with them oh really stressful yes it's
very very different ways of looking at
you have to understand anyway we just
went right away from that that's fine
have you ever ever watched my brother my
brother and me listen to - yes that's
that podcast is so much funnier than
dear Hank and John and they never talked
about the questions the goal is
different they never talk about death I
mean jeez what kind of podcast is it
even seriously come on gotta least
acknowledge it yeah I just want to talk
about my brother my brother and me every
like every episode of dear Hank and John
because I want all the people who want
who listened to dear Hank and John to
know there's so much of it though there
is you don't solicit that's the other
thing you are like you feel like there's
all these objects in the queue of of my
brother my brother and me and that's
stressful but you're never gonna listen
to all of them yeah but I'm just like oh
I'll just listen to the most recent one
and if I listen to that one I listen to
one before that
oh man no I wasn't one of the first ones
and I was like why did I do this it's
that's good they didn't know what they
were doing the audio quality is bad
then I mean it's like it's not not funny
it's good that's good why would you
start at the beginning when like what
like sometimes I'm like why would
someone start at the big no one would
start the beginning of vlogbrothers you
would go back and watch vlogbrothers
maybe because you have like you want to
like have a solid start that's that we
gonna start because if you did you'd be
like what this is awful this is why why
did anyone ever watch this it's terrible
terrible video you have super awkward
people super awkward
low quality both technically and as far
as the actual concert equipments nice
all right Katherine yeah we want to do
another question I think we should okay
sorry we didn't really answer that one
but you know let's do a more serious
question
oh okay sure yeah this one is from Laura
who asks dear Hank and Katherine doesn't
actually say that but let's just go with
it whatever I'm in college and I have
had a boyfriend for a year and a half I
love spending time and going places with
him and his family but I'm often
uncomfortable because they are a very
rich and I am definitely not rich his
parents took us out to some fancy
dinners for which I have to buy fancy
clothes that I can't afford and it's an
odd situation for me because I never
went out for fancy dinners growing up do
you have any dubious advice for me to
how to feel more comfortable in
situations like this two different
questions here yeah I mean there's
definitely several issues yeah Laura is
it it is well Laura what do you think
that's okay I feel like I had a not not
quite us but not the exact yeah
experiences you that's why I thought
this would be a good question a similar
one Hanks you had to say family parts of
it at least are far better off than mine
and just had different expectations of
what what life was going to be like
right um and that included you know
fancy fancy cocktail parties and what up
the country event yes things that things
at the Country Club and you know where
if you were raised with it it wouldn't
seem strange at all
mm-hmm but as an outsider and especially
someone even from a slightly different
culture mm-hmm I grew up in Connecticut
my family is from the south
so not quite the same there did not have
you know anyway yeah I don't know about
needing to get more comfortable with
that I think it's all right to maintain
the discomfort mm-hmm in some aspect
right I mean like because like you don't
want to be I don't know a different
person right and also like to become
comfortable with fancy dinners all the
time mm-hmm
I don't know I see I mean this is me
judging right but you want to be a
little more connected to reality yeah
yeah yeah you not not everyone is able
to do that obviously right like you're
like you're saying you know and it's the
kind of thing that you want to
appreciate as exceptional right not the
kind of thing that we want to consider
as normal yeah and thanks for putting
those words out there because I was
having a hard time with it
I yeah it's fine I am a professional
talker and I didn't want to sound judge
by never coming to my mind was sort of a
judgmental yeah um because you know it's
it's a cultural difference and like
people who are who are like ingrained in
a culture can have a very difficult time
realizing how exceptional it might be at
the same time even the even like sort of
lower middle class experience in America
is a much as a as a luxurious lifestyle
globally yeah so like there's always
that kind of yeah yeah tension I'd say
yeah I mean to help you with the thing
about feeling more comfortable
um you could just have like your own
personal like maybe a little game you
play like how many times does something
strange happen or yeah something that
seems I don't know I can't think of a
specific event you can kind of consider
it times does the waiter say your
boyfriend's dad's name or call him
mister something yeah or whatever I
don't whatever it is I don't know well
yeah what are your consider it sort of
an anthropological experiment what
Catherine is suggesting yes and with
time it does get more you know
appreciate it yes you know and be like
wow this is really interesting yeah
delicious yeah and yeah yeah yeah uh but
but then as far as like this this what I
consider to be the practical problem
yeah of like I need to buy clothes for
these experiences they don't concede if
achill for a rich person to consider
that with like they're taking you out as
a gift to you right and they have no
idea and will probably be terrified to
hear that you have to spend what is a
significant amount of money to you and
like make a significant sacrifice in
order to have this experience and and
the hope is that like these people just
want to make you feel comfortable feel
happy yeah and and feel supported and
they don't know that that's happening
now figuring out how to tell them that
that's happening without like it being
really awkward is hard yeah I mean if if
I my question is if you have you ever
discussed this with your boyfriend right
you've got you've been together for two
years
yeah okay well that's not very long
enough to maybe to bring it up yeah be
like he knows something about your
family yeah and also you know like maybe
you're like well I love seeing your
family mm-hmm could we do something else
next time right whatever it is yeah I
love seeing your family and I and like
hey yeah just like approaching it from
like a purely rational standpoint might
be a nice thing to do and be like is it
okay if I wear the same dress every time
yeah
I would definitely I would do that
because there is also a kind of the same
dress every time yeah they'd put a
different scarf on yeah or you know
don't think you have to get a different
dress for every time you go out yeah I
mean chances are they will not even
notice yeah and if they do and if they
do and they don't like it then like
that's a conversation that you have to
have with your boyfriend because then
they're judging you for your yeah before
like something that is not in your
control which is not something that good
people do yep sometimes you you fall in
love with people who don't have good
relatives bad sounds like they're nice
it sounds like they're nice it sounds
like you've got a good situation and
well it'll be totally hopefully handle
the ball hopefully I don't know just
stick just stick with it if you feel
like it and if you don't don't don't
that's good advice Catherine do you want
to ask another question oh sure
this one's also kind of serious but it's
from Emily who asks dear Hank and
Catherine how do I get over my anxiety
associated with driving mmm I was hit by
a car my freshman year of high school
and broke my ankle and had to be in
physical therapy for a very long time
now I guess because I now understand the
real dangers of driving a car I don't
like driving it is the source of most of
my anxiety I'm a senior in high school
and have had my learner's permit for a
year and a half how do I get over this
anxiety and actually drive mmm very
America question yeah yeah yeah cause in
America like for people who aren't don't
live American lifestyles including
people in America who might live in big
cities yeah driving is very like often
times you can't do things without a
driver's license that have nothing to do
with driving yeah like like it is your
identity your piece of identification
you can get non driver's license
identification yeah they're much more
rare yeah and and and driving is very
like a like a very necessary part of
life in a lot of a lot of America and
you basically can't function as an adult
without the ability to do it and in some
places or it is a significant or have
any sort of social apps yeah it can hold
you back significant
yeah it's it's really unfortunate that
that is the case I mean yeah where I
lived in Connecticut I lived in a very
sort of rural rural area and I
specifically did not live near anyone I
was friends with mm-hmm
so if I ever wanted to go see anyone I
had to get myself there because no one
was going to come to my house no city
yes no and also yeah there was no public
transport yeah um at all so and also
like if I wanted to have a job or do
anything extracurricular mm-hmm
sports or musicals or any of that stuff
I had to be able to get myself to those
things my dad didn't you know like my
mom couldn't drive me yeah she had a job
she had a job
yeah yeah but I mean your anxiety
associated with driving is is good yes
it is warranted it is the most because
you know it is the most dangerous thing
that young people do yeah
and the it is less dangerous
automatically because you are anxious
about it because you are going to be
careful about it the in general like
that the blanket advice is if you have
to do something that you're anxious
about doing it is the only way to get
less anxious about it yep and the more
you do it the less anxious you will feel
I mean I I remember I'm using no I don't
know where you live
yeah but I would take yourself somehow
to a place that is more safe yeah to
begin drive I do a lot of driving around
in neighborhoods yep the low 20 miles
per hour low places
with not a lot of other cars and not a
lot of other things to challenge you
yeah and just get comfortable with the
actual like being in a car in the
driver's seat yeah and you know take it
as slow as you need to
yeah I guess and and and and as far as
like rash
Hank just to know that like all things
are percentages and and the chances of
you know sort of normal everyday driving
not being reckless the chances of injury
are low yeah especially the slower year
go slower yeah you the chances of
accidents are much higher when you're
going slower but the chances of injury
yeah injury are much lower this is a
very interesting I mean I did I did a
bunch of weird research on now so I read
a statistic on the internet that said
that women were much more likely to be
in car to be the cause of car accidents
than men and I was like mmm I don't feel
good about this statistic so I did a bit
more I did a bunch of research and it
was fascinating and it was it wasn't it
is indeed true but they are much less
likely to be the cause of deadly
accidents so women do a lot of
neighborhood driving driving to school a
lot of like distracted yeah like mall
parking lot driving like the kind of
driving that you're likely to get into
an accident in supermarkets yeah like
like this is where most women they go
and shop they driving it kids around
yeah and they also have like the most
distracting thing you can possibly have
in a car which is a child yes but but
you know what what are we what do we
want to measure here at the number of
fender benders or the number of like
deaths because men are responsible for
many more actual debt like serious car
accidents which is fascinating and one
of those things where you're like boy
statistics they can say anything fire
but yeah neighborhood driving is very
safe and and it is all and that whatever
happened to you I'm sorry about your
accident it's you know it's on you just
happened to be statistically very
unlucky and and that happens that does
not mean that that it seems much more
present to you because it has happened
to you but that does not mean that it is
as likely as it feels to you which is an
important thing we've got another
question this is from a Liana who asks
why do Sesame why do sesame seeds add to
a burger why do buns always have sesame
seeds
Eliana I don't know and I am so so
grateful for you two for asking
have you brought this up before no I
don't think I have I don't know that
I've ever mentioned this anywhere
publicly I can't eat sesame seeds
because of my own sort of colitas they
they are a trigger food for me that will
make my colon really unhappy and and so
so like basically sesame seeds are hank
repellent and like I get oh man
and they just like sprinkle on
everything nearly no warning like this
is not a garnish no for the food I had
nothing no I like I love the flavor of
sesame I can't taste it and it's on a
bun yeah like two seeds on a bun no no
it is just and like they stick there so
stuck on because they like paint them on
with egg whites or something I don't
know but you can't just brush them off
and I it is so every time I get it
sandwich at a restaurant have to be like
does it have sesame - no it does have
something seasoned I'm like fine just
give me a freaking sabotage and often
times I'll be at places particularly
Asian restaurants and I I don't know why
I haven't a hundred percent asked every
time but you get a thing and it doesn't
say anything about sesame seeds and then
it's covered in sesame seeds yes they've
just they've just thrown a handful of
sesame seeds over your sushi and you're
like I know someone I hope I hope so
much that someone else will eat this
because I cannot yeah but but I think
that this is just a like fast food is
very strange I was thinking about it
yesterday because we were eating at
McDonald's and uh and I realize what our
secret is out yeah and I was thinking
about like the food that they have in
McDonald's and why it is the way it is
cuz I was having an Egg McMuffin it was
nighttime I bet I had it because they
can do that i McDonald's now
sponsor yeah they have all-day breakfast
it's very exciting and I was like why is
it like why is this the thing that I can
get why is it chicken sandwich in a
hamburger why are the these the things
yeah and it's because they like have
this overlap between being what was in
the 50s and when like fast-food
restaurants were starting to happen what
was considered good food and what is
easily able what you were easily able to
cheaply cook
and get and distribute with the same
limited set of equipment and in easy
training for employees and that's
basically what the food is
at McDonald's it's stuff that's easy to
get to places easy to train people to
cook and easy and you don't have to have
a new piece of equipment to cook it
that's all the stuff and and I think
that sesame seeds are there because they
add legitimacy to a hamburger they make
it seem like this is like somebody
thought about this and sesame seeds like
on a baked good like if you're going to
a bakery and like there are these like
Coco trios that like have amazing oh
yeah sesame seeds all over me bagel and
so like it's a thing that like is is
indicative of a higher quality item that
I'm sure costs very little money so it
looks higher quality without being
functionally different at all but it
looks higher quality and doesn't cost
much more and I think that that is a
huge huge part of the sesame seed
industry in the world window dressing
yeah it is psychology
yes psychology psychological window
dressing makes you think you're yeah I'm
getting a faint eating a fancier product
yeah mm-hmm I have a lot of thoughts on
this unsurprisingly because I deal with
it and this is also a problem for people
with diverticulitis a yeah so it's it's
it's not a huge problem globally
you know I understand that there are
other food issues that are more
significant I let my assess me see
problem but I yes I I am a frustration I
am a frustration you are a frustration
all right Hank you want another question
give me one this one's also kind of
about food
it's from Rabia arabia Rubbia
okay
dear Hank and Catherine so we got cheesy
pepperoni pizza delivered to our house
the other day it sounds delicious I want
I want it extra pepperoni
mmm crispy and amazing no God it was
delicious and I think my sister would
agree since she slowly reached for the
last slice maintaining solid eye contact
her face cold and unsmiling and almost
threatening gesture that took a turn how
can we learn to forgive people and to
move on when we know they have
intentionally hurt us why do we even
have why do we even talk we shouldn't
let these people make the drugs
first of all Rabia beautiful or the
beautiful story I was transported to
another place I could see that Pizza mm
I could I could taste it and smell it so
crispy and then I saw your sisters
betrayal yeah I saw the face mm yeah
cold intentional well I I think that
there's uh I think you should steal her
ball I think there's only one thing you
can do sake said follow up follow I
think it was Laura's lead and steal
steal that it wasn't Laura dang it then
Natalie madeley's lead steal that ball
take it
don't don't even wanna know where it is
yeah I mean that's one way to handle it
just retribution yeah sure
steal her boyfriends what does she love
destroy it does she have a collection of
porcelain horses put them in the blender
crush them dust dust sand and then mix
them in with her hot cocoa
that would be really really a fairy yeah
that would really don't do that don't do
that Catherine oh that's like tiny tiny
pieces of glass in your drink
yeah I know you don't want that on your
drink no you also don't want to be that
person I want to tell a story about
Catherine one time story about you yes
you know what I'm gonna tell yes oh man
so Kelly did an internship at a at a
wildlife rehab place and she was living
in a dorm basically with a bunch of
other people and things this guy and the
dorm that Catherine really didn't like
he was really annoying and he was
difficult and he was mean and I can't
even really remember
I agree like I said met him and I also
really did not of why I disliked him but
yes this is not it yes he was an
unpleasant person and he was very yeah
and memory of and I was visiting
Catherine in this dorm and she admitted
to me that she would when no one was
looking
squeeze his fruit to the shared kitchen
area and I would just like squeeze all
his pears so that they would get brown
spots you never gonna get there with a
person to fruit squeezing no I know I
know you're not proud I'm so very
passive yeah a lot of door slamming in
my life mm-hmm yep yeah and that's just
important to keep those lines of
communication open so that we don't get
to fruit squeezy okay face yeah you know
but I didn't care about maintaining a
relationship with this person no it's
not like I was really just gonna have a
conversation with him about not leaving
his dirty things everywhere and yeah
just stop stop being a terrible person
yeah
anyway one of the community living is a
challenge yes
communal living is a huge challenge oh
boy is it yeah I'm glad I only have to
do that with one other person yeah yeah
yeah we do pretty well we do it pretty
well I have another question
oh good yeah so squeeze squeeze our
fruit is the answer the question yeah
yeah I mean maybe like don't squeeze our
freak no no but like something that is
really inconsequential that'll make you
feel better yeah you know like just go
unfold all of her t-shirts or something
[Applause]
but you'll feel better you gotta let it
go you gotta let it go you gotta ask
yourself you know what I could do is
just order another pizza and there would
be more pizza like like there's not a
limited amount of feet so in your say
yeah I guess that's true there's other
there's other pizza in the world will be
more pizza I guess you just gotta you
gotta let it go
this girl Lydia who has naked Katherine
and this question is for both of us so
it says this question is for Hank but it
is about Montana no she's just been
accepted into a summer program at
Montana State University is she's super
excited but she's also scared because
she lives in Amsterdam and the
Netherlands and has no idea what to
expect from Bozeman Montana it's pretty
different right yes then then yes that's
correct it's pretty different than
Missoula actually so Hank what's Montana
like what should i do there will I be
able to do things without a driver's
license and most importantly how many
sides do bananas have in Montana
anything you can tell me about this epic
looking place would be very much
appreciated all right yes bananas
interestingly are clones and so they
look the same everywhere in the world at
least for now until the blight kills
them all
you can watch about that on scishow Wow
so yeah bananas look the same here
unless you're talking about a different
species of banana plug II well yeah and
I'm Hank GRE on snapchat
oh boy anyway um Montana
I mean have you ever been to the United
States yes your first introduction yeah
like um I've never been to Amsterdam so
I don't really know but I have some
ideas about it do you like beer we
really like beer here and that's a big
part of the culture
first of all you're gonna have to start
drinking espresso mm-hmm and beer well
she may have just just been accepted
into school so she probably technically
can't drink in America but it's MSU so
right you probably gonna have beer
around that's a good point
unless that's not that's that bag you
probably find people who are into
whatever you're into the thing is they
don't really know much about Bozeman I
don't know that much about Bose I do not
know what that Ingrid is there right now
how not she's not there she's just
nearby anyway I don't know how easy it
is to get around in that town without a
car but I bet you could do it yeah
they'd really be smaller too you just
have to pick where you live carefully
yep and also what you want to do on a
daily basis yeah there's a website
called Walk Score oh yeah and and and so
if you're looking for apartments you
probably gonna live on campus yeah yeah
it's a if you live on campus then you'll
probably be set without a car you'll
have friends who have cars and and
campus would probably be near most of
the services you need unless you want to
go out to like go to Walmart or yeah a
movie theater or something then you will
need someone's car but if you want yeah
it is certainly more sprawling than you
yeah yeah but there's a downtown area
but yes yeah what should you do here is
that what yeah yeah I think you know in
any new place like the trick is finding
a group of people who have like sort of
a similar outlook and values as you and
that you know that might be a struggle
because there are more American sort of
like gung-ho American types in Bozeman
yes they're more conservative yeah
people yes but you will be going to a
college and so there will be plenty of
yeah plenty I'm not that sure but you're
real close to Yellowstone oh yeah you
should
go to Yellowstone friends because that
requires a car but like yeah it's it can
be expensive to get in you paper car so
the more people you have that go with
you the cheaper it is better and you can
also it's a week-long pass I believe
once you pay to get into the park
no make make a make a longer trip out of
it don't just plan on going down there
for a day or something also because it's
huge and you won't be able to see
anything and you'll be really stressed
out yeah if you try to get it all into
one yeah um but yeah and also I don't
know do you like to fish try that out or
hike
there's great faking all over but there
are bears there so make sure you bring a
bear Bell and and bear spray they do
mauled by them everything sometimes get
killed by there just happen here in
Missoula so much that's true we have not
had any maulings since we've been here
it's a different landscape up there it's
the other side of the Continental Divide
I don't know man just explores the
landscape like you go as many places as
you can if you can find someone to take
you there you can't drive hi it's a
lovely time to walk around in and do you
have I don't know what time of year
you're going to be there it's gonna be
winter make sure you bring a lot of
coats it's cold it's cold lots of snow
there'll be lots of snow and if you like
skiing that is the thing that lots of
people do they're sure that that can
also be expensive though so what kind of
college student budget allows for going
to the skiing no no no I'm I don't know
different strokes yeah it's hard to
answer because they don't know what you
want to yeah I think we gave it by them
you give a pretty good I love you are
you coming here to do
she didn't say oh just just go to school
yeah she's super excited
that's a weird decision she said that
she's excited about the epic looking
place so it is epic looking big
mountains
beautiful Valley mm-hmm yep don't get
into the sports though the football is
too much it's too much it's just too
much we got a lot like we don't have any
national football teams in Montana so
it's all about the college and it just
it rubs me the wrong way you guys know
I'll be honest we don't hurt us but you
know everybody in Mozilla knows we've
had some issues we've had some issues
yeah and it's really frustrating you've
got another question for us Kathryn I
sure this one's from Emmett Emmett yeah
Dear John Hank and Hank John and
Catherine Catherine a few years ago I
dated a rapper oh cool I now count him
among my most amicable exes but on
account of the fact that breakups suck
and I initiated ours he wrote a song
about me and the immediate aftermath
that is he confesses somewhat harsh when
we were dating he offered me veto power
over any lyrics about me which I
declined on the principle that
respecting each other's creative freedom
was important in a relationship between
artists
he's generously floated the same offer
about the post-breakup song before it's
committed to posterity in his upcoming
album I am still firm in my principles
so my answer hasn't changed what has
changed is that I don't want to hear the
song at all in fact I'd read it I can
accept that the song will be out in the
world but I don't want it in my world I
plan on immediately deleting it from my
copy of the album and stepping out for
an imaginary cigarette if I go to a live
show having a song written about you as
a pretty cool experience so it's
ridiculous to duck out of that just
because it might hurt some very so is it
ridiculous to duck out of that just
because it might hurt some very old
feelings he accepts my decision but it
still feels a bit sticky especially as
I'm creating some merch related to the
new album for him please I implore your
dubious advice as to whether I come off
as perfectly reasonable or an emotional
coward in this scenario I met you come
off as perfectly reasonable yeah I mean
it's okay to have feelings about things
that happen
the past his feelings are all right
Catherine Catherine accepts the
legitimacy of feelings and as should you
and as should your ex yeah I and I mean
it yeah uh are you worried about I'm
confused about why are you worried about
this yeah are you worried that he is
going to react badly to your reaction or
that other people are going to see you
leaving and be like oh he's leaving cuz
the song is about him and I wouldn't
worry about either of those things
no I think you it is fine too
yeah to take steps to protect yourself
yeah yeah no that's fine and I'd like
and it's C I mean I'm mostly I'm just a
little worried that you still have such
a close relationship with this person
but that's okay it's fine yeah I don't
know how long ago this breakup was or
anything so how bad it was yeah it says
it's amicable so yeah I I think that you
are both being very healthy in this
situation and I I think that if your ex
feels like you are behaving strangely
like it is fine to say like it's just
you know it's it's emotional for me to
hear that song and so like if I don't
want to have a bunch of emotions right
now which I don't always want right and
I'm at a club yeah then I like then I'm
not gonna listen to it and then like but
like but at the same time like I like I
you know like you in this situation are
being really supportive of creative
endeavor and that's very healthy and
fantastic and like it's a cool outlook
that you seem to both have on the
situation so good good job yeah I think
I like this question basically because
because I think you got all that yeah I
like this question cuz it's just like
hello I'm handling a difficult situation
in a very healthy way can we talk about
that for a little
yes let's do that and let's talk about
you you handling a healthy you handling
a difficult thing in a healthy way I
feel good now good job yeah people make
good decisions sometimes not always what
we get here on D rangam John an easy one
yeah I yep well worded question and
everything yeah you read the whole thing
was a long one it was long I I was like
okay I'm still reading it you did good
you better at reading than me we got
other question this one's from Nicole
who asks dear Hank and Catherine this
one's senior I'm a freshman has
complimented my giraffe love shirt on
two different occasions it makes me
wonder if he's a nerdfighter however I
wear my dftba sweatshirt every day to
school and he's never said anything
about that
is he a nerdfighter or does he just
really like giraffes Wow well I think I
think it's probably guessing that he
really likes her a supposed to be like
he really likes giraffes and also love
and love and also probably you maybe
also he thinks you're cute but do not be
caged do not engage do not engage
freshmen save your complicated power
dynamic do not engage Catherines got a
got a grown face yeah we've all seen it
we've all seen that in bounce power
dynamic I just don't think it's good
anyway you didn't ask about that at all
didn't um I don't think he's a
nerdfighter either yeah but because it's
possible that he just doesn't know he is
yet that's right so next time he
complements it you should hand him a
piece of papers maybe you'd enjoy this
website dftba.com or you can buy this
shirt no HTTP colon slash slash
youtube.com slash vlogbrothers nobody
puts HTTP I know I don't know why you
were doing that I don't either
Triple dub as they say on the old person
radio oh god yeah I never heard that oh
yeah oh that gives me
all kinds of gross feeling yeah it's
gross yeah I I heard that on I heard
that when I was at your parents house
there was a or was it a tech support
program on the AM radio I was like how
to use your computer and like cater
advice this is clearly a person who like
actually knows what they're talking
about but also knows that their audience
does not it was very interesting to
listen to and I will never forget it I
just want to say the bat shirt anything
isn't happening my parents yes it's a
great shirt and I designed it so thank
you no I'm fat I just want to say thank
you to both you and that random senior
interrupts and your apps thank you to
giraffes and also other people who have
also had the thought of making a heart
shape out of giraffe necks that is not
yes which is not a thing that Hank owns
yes
yeah the turn I often will get people
being like did you see they copied your
design and I'm like it's a it's a
giraffe it's a couple giraffes making a
heart thank you that's the original
that's gonna happen come up with that
one all by yourself I showed it this
podcast Hank
yes it's brought to you by giraffes oh
yeah they're tall they got long necks
and they eat leaves correct they're
great they can make heart shapes with
their necks and they drink each other's
pee yeah giraffes I mean they will make
your life more interesting if they
certainly did to us I mean frankly not
only is this podcast brought to you by
giraffes but in a way the entire
vlogbrothers Enterprises is brought to
you by giraffes and if you check out our
most our most viewed videos this episode
of dear Hank and John is also brought to
you by the warmth of your dog or cat the
warmth of your dog or cat just remember
that they feel you as a cold sack of
human flesh this episode of dear Hank
and John is brought to you by your
siblings ball
[Applause]
that came out different than you wanted
your step help your siblings ball maybe
you should just give it back if you
really want it and finally of course
this episode of dear Hank Jones brought
to you by a sesame seeds the american
association of sesame sounds is not not
brought to you by sesame seeds because
they can go oh wait this episode of dear
Hank and John is finally brought to you
by good decisions oh yeah good decision
a healthier system are able to make them
and when you do we are proud of you yes
well done write us lettuce your question
and say I was in a difficult situation
made a good decision and will just be
like good job thank you
well done you alright well I don't what
a wonderful episode of your hang a
travel you have had thus far do you want
to do a a couple more questions
ah I suppose we could do questions or is
it time for the news from AFC Wimbledon
and marce what time is it oh it's it's
totally wow wow that flew by we it is
time for the news from AFC Wimbledon and
Mars jeez Catherine I didn't realize how
how how time we had gone how time we had
gone yes it does had gone without us
experiencing it sometimes
well the newsroom AFC Wimbledon is not I
it's not great hopefully this is the
newest news good I'm proud of you
already Catherine from the 8th of March
okay that was two days ago that's new
sure that's got to be accurate um
unfortunately AFC Wimbledon lost their
game to the Bristol Rovers Oh No 3-1 and
they are currently in seventh oh that's
still that's still good seventh I think
is in side of the going up to deal with
the possible possible promotion but more
challenging more chat what happened I
just refreshed this frickin page and it
has data is taking extremely long to
load but once it loads I will tell you
all kinds of things that happened
something indeed did happen several at
least four distinct goals happened yep
yep
Jemaine Easter nodded Rovers ahead from
Lee Browns cross before Ollie Clarke
doubled the lead with a low right footed
shot Oh John Meads header gave Wimbledon
hope Oh John Meads go John needs yeah
but Matt Taylor's 12 yard finish his
19th of the season sealed victory I feel
like this was plagiarized oh sorry
BBC Sport website women who are seventh
as I said had substitute out of bio
Aachen phenoix sent off oh oh no descent
descent like it's like its World War two
I don't know in the ranks he just said
he dissented anyway Derrida there at 53
points ah
that's such is tied with Leyton Orient
but they have a better goal differential
so that's why they're in seventh place
but there are four points behind their
nearest mm-hmm you can make that up yeah
it's possible I suppose but they're not
gonna get into that top three hmm I do
not think it is going to happen this
year all right Catherine well the
newsroom that is the end of the news
from AFC Wimbledon thank God all right
gathered this is the news from Mars the
Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter or of her
for her what is a Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter okay
celebrates its 10th anniversary what
today when we record this several days
previously Thursday March and the Mars
Reconnaissance Orbiter has been doing
amazing research on Mars taking pictures
with a number of differ
instruments of the surface of Mars that
have in is a satellite it is a satellite
around the around the planet of Mars
correct the planet of Cecilia also known
as Mars would you designate Mars Oh the
joke only for Sparks Nevada fans I can't
believe I've never met a Sparks Nevada
joke and all of this time seriously of
doing tell me more about Chico loot rock
guitar which you designate everyone
calls it Mars everyone calls mark have
you never heard the thrilling adventure
hour podcast you should totally check it
out it's amazing it is a old timey radio
podcast all time radio and new to it is
a new time podcast in the style of
old-time radio there it is narratives I
remembered it is no longer it is no
longer a thing that is happening but
there's lots of old episodes and they're
absolutely delightful
so delight so delight so delightful also
recommend beyond belief yes with paget
Brewster and Paul F Tompkins hop
top-quality hilarity top-quality
hilarity um anyway so the rover is ten
years old Orbiter right it is orbiting
not going out on the surface it has
lasted five times longer than they
expected it to last that is amazing and
it has been amazing because as we have
found out more stuff we have been able
to focus on areas of Mars and do
research like on those streaks of water
then we have recently identified those
so if we did not have if it had not
lasted as long as it did we would not
have been able to do that research and
we would not know that there was liquid
water on the surface of Mars sometimes
for brief amounts of time fascinating
fascinating thank you good work thank
you to all of the product scientists at
the MRO team thank you to the orbiter
itself which is obviously does it have a
name
the mrl the doors oh god no it doesn't
it doesn't get like curiosity here now
opportunity's spirit can we call it Fred
sure call it sparks it work sparks
sparks is good
MassPike she's got a bad you don't want
you don't want an orbiter to spark in
space no it has also given us a much
better look at the surface of Mars
so that croch yeah croch the orbiter
that's also giving us a much better look
at the surface of mars so that we can
better plan missions to Mars and and had
a better ability to land in the places
where we wanted to land safely which we
did with curiosity so thank you to the
Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter for your 10
years of service and all the people on
those teams and congratulations well
well done
what do we learn today Katherine oh boy
is it that time already we did I just
deleted all my notes didn't realize I
did forgot about that part of vodka Oh
well Hank we learned that it's okay to
have anxiety about driving but if you
gotta learn to do it you gotta do it you
gotta do it that is the only way to be
less anxious about the things that you
do and that goes for pretty much
everything in which everything yep we
learned that your dog or cat hates it
when you touch them oh but they have no
way of knowing but they're just so
stalwart they're good at just dealing
with it it could it deal dealing with it
don't you if they didn't like it they
would leave that's true that's true
that's what I always tell my cat if you
don't like if I'm bothering her like
then leave you can just go away then
leave so yes cats and dogs they find us
to be sexes of flesh but they don't mind
but they don't mind we also learned that
sesame seeds are from the devil
they're from the devil sesame seeds who
needs them just sprinkle them in the
fire and the fire and brimstone sesame
seeds
I love honestly like it is one of the
things that I miss the most I do love
sesame seeds now sesame flavored things
but I just you can't taste them so why
why if you're gonna use this SME see put
them in like a sesame stick that tastes
like sesame mm-hmm yep poor sesame seeds
poor sesame score
poor me um poor Hank we learned that
sometimes you'll want to do petty things
to pay your sister back for eating the
cheesy pizza but you probably shouldn't
just go squeeze her fruit and unfold all
of her laundry you should just let it go
Catherine does not look committed to
this line of thought she said it but her
eyes her eyes did not agree we learned
the last thing we learned is that my
wife she doesn't and I probably should
put my cups away don't cross me should
probably put my cups away you guys thank
you for listening to this episode of
dear Hank and Catherine also sometimes
steer John and Hank and dear Hank and
John yes it has been a great time having
you with us if you have questions you
can send them to dear Hank and John dear
dear Hank and John just slain Hank and
John at gmail.com we are also on Twitter
John is John Green I am Hank green do
you want to tell people your twitter is
no don't follow me on social media I say
nothing interesting and you could send
them to us on the patreon and fight
SoundCloud yes even a patreon support
thanks for your patreon support thank
you much appreciated by our editor who
is Nicholas Jenkins our intern who is
Claudia Morales our theme music is by
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget the awesome
[Music]